really more of a talk with questions and
search for answers the answers that I
have are not as good as I wish thick
they could be so maybe people can help
me out a little bit and it's very eye
level very conceptual I hope not a lot
of technical details so and this is
joint work with my student material
component lee okay so let me tell you
what the model is I'm going to talk
about very fabric computation in a model
in which the adversary is not malicious
but rather an irrational entity and by
that I mean that the bursary is only
interested in maximizing a well-defined
utility function that is defined inside
the protocol so and our results which
I'll you know describe better endure in
a talk we started from this notion of
rational proof that Sylvia McCauley and
Pablo's are introduced a couple of years
ago a stock in which and so we started
from that model which was a model of a
standalone protocol in which one
computation is out sourced from a client
to a server and we sort of extended the
model we were motivated by the problem
of volunteer computations stuff like
protein folding or SETI at home and
actually does this started that I wanted
my student to implement a volunteer
computation client based on rational
proofs and as he started working on that
he is that is noticing this problem and
the problem is a problem which we have a
source of many problems that have to be
out sourced and now we wanted to make
sure that the notion of rational proof
was robust enough to deal with the case
in which providing the correct results
on all the computation would be the
actual rational strategy and we ended up
showing the sum of the non-rational
proofs according to the definition of
mcallen Azhar as our Macaulay do not
satisfy our notion of sequential
composability
I hope is the correct one and so then we
present a new rational proof protocol
and this is the part of what I wish our
results were better because you only
works for certain function and for
certain for certain stuff is not as
general as I hope it was going to be
okay so let's let's talk about rational
proofs this is an interactive proof
between approval and a verifier the
input is a function f and a value ax and
at the end of the other protocol the
proofer provides the verifier with a
value Y and the verifier pays the prover
with a randomized reward which is a
function of the transcript of the
conversation between the two the two of
them the crucial property of Russian of
proofs is that this river this reward
should be maximized in expectation when
the prover provides the correct result
if the prove it is a rational entity
therefore it will only do the right
stuff always compute correctly the most
attractive feature of Russian Oprah
visit is a very very simple macaulay
honors our show that there's a one-round
proof for the whole class of peep of PP
and a cost around proof for the counting
hierarchy and yeah we're talking about
proofs in which we have an all-powerful
proven of course to deal with such a
large complexity class and a polynomial
time very far this is the original
notion of interactive proof with an
infinitely powerful proven a paleta poly
time verify of course yeah infinitely
powerful prover verify the verify the
reward is polynomial time polynomial
time computer box every far is honest
it's not like zero knowledge in which
you have a malicious verify here your
security is defined only in
the verifier is honest in this model
that's that that's outside the scope of
that yeah then you if if the if the
verifier boards then you code this in
hock and you'll be sure will be
penalized right right yeah yeah the verb
in this case there in this entire set in
the verifier zone we are interested in a
deficient scenario in which we have a
polynomial time computation and if c is
the complexity of computing this
function we would like to have a prove
our which is pretty much the complexity
of computing the function and a verifier
which is a lot faster than computing the
function and azhari mccauley we're aware
that that's actually the application you
want to look at and there the subsequent
paper in which they present a very
efficient verify are verified that
actually doesn't even read in d put a
sub linear actually runs only lock time
and they present a cost around protocol
for uniform you need you need your
circuit to be uniform because the
verifier needs to be able to a lot time
need to be able to access parts of the
circuit and for threshold circuits and
this is possible there was a work by
Ernest alone this year alone and some of
his co-workers authors in which they
extend this to actually log depth
circuits if we alai if you allow the
very hard to be poly log rather than lot
ok let me briefly show you how the
threshold protocols of the macaulay
azhar paper works so just for simplicity
we have a single threshold gate with any
inputs and the special gates evaluates
to 1 if at least k of the inputs are 1
ok so what does the prove it does the
prove apiece read the inputs and then
announced a number M tilde of input bits
that are equal to one so it's going to
tell the verifier there are this many
inputs that one
so and this number and kill the definer
probability P tilde which is the
probability that if you choose a random
bit that be will be one this is the
probability claimed by the prover to be
the case okay so what does the very far
does the very far says okay tell you're
telling me that's the number one search
the number one is bigger than k i'm
going to set my output to one otherwise
i'm gonna set it to zero and then to
compute the reward the verifier selects
a random input i run them yeah rumbling
input in among the n inputs and look at
the input bit b which is the value X I
the input X I and then here's where they
use this notion from prediction theory
it's a it comes from economics it's
something that is used to reward weather
prediction and stock market prediction
it's called there are several that are
called scoring rules and they use Briers
rule and the brighter this rules our way
to measure to reward a well you are
nouns a certain distribution so think of
this protocol as the prover is
announcing a distribution which is P
tilde right the progress telling you if
you select a random bit among these n
bits the probability that you get one it
should be pitting that that's exactly
what you're going to do you're going to
go and select an input bit and you would
expect it to be 1 with probability P
tilde and this is the amount of money
that you're going to pay it's a function
of the Patil that it was announced in
number one or the other bit one of the
bit 0 that you found and so what's the
expectation of the other reward
disposition there were this this one
where instead of Patil that is the real
probability P that are the bit that you
selected would be 1 or 0 right it turns
out that isn't not difficult to see that
this value is maximized when the Patil
that there is an ounce is equal to P
yea it's not his explanation no I'll get
to that in a minute okay in this case is
not is the inverse of a polynomial okay
so okay this is the this is the protocol
no matter what the prove it announced
the prove it gets some money the trick
is that this money in expectation is
higher when the proof says the truth let
me briefly say something I'm talking
about the reward what about the prophet
of the prover right there's a cost
involved in computing this function so
the prophet the prophet of the prover is
the reward that he gets minus the cost
of the function well consider a lazy
prove er which invests very little
effort and yes it gets paid right so
what we want we want the profit to be
maximized right so you want r minus C to
be bigger than our tilde minus T tilde
so there's sufficient to require the r
minus r still is bigger than C which
means you get a look at the boat
Alessandro saying the reward up the
reward gap is this the smallest gap
between the math that the reward doors
on the donors prove it gets and the
reward by this honest prove ER and if
you call that Delta if you multiply your
rewards by a factor of C times Delta
then your this is always true because
our matter are still is going to be C
times out c divided by delta x delta s
is always going to be bigger than C ok
so in and if Delta is one over a
polynomial your nothing is going nothing
is becoming exponential I'm so we're all
fine right in particular in the previous
protocol the original reward is always a
number between 0 and 2 it's not hard to
see that the the Delta is actually the
reward gap is 1 over n square so if I
n97 announcing the right number announce
the right number minus 1 which is really
what gets your closer you're going to
get other word which is
in expectation 1 over the square smaller
okay and that means that if you scale
your rewards by oops again x factor of n
cube you're fine okay but this is in the
one time case okay yeah so computational
cost so it's it you know look at this is
to say if if I'm going to be paying as
much I might as well do the computation
myself if computation costs me the same
thing it costs you right so it sure is
assumption that we well this is right so
that that's does the whole computing
paradigm is is predicated on that that
what everybody costs amazon to provide
me with to compute this function is
already cost me to compute this fine
right so but this is this is this gap is
the gap between what the reward the
honest proper gets and the dishonest
ruin my rewards by you know the sin
square factor right right okay but this
is the cost for the server is not the
cost for me okay so okay yeah it will
yeah okay so let's put that aside for a
minute okay so but let me give you an
example of a lazy pooper for example in
this protocol to consider proving that
answer a random which takes it's a
constant strategy cost and cost strategy
well if you take the expected if you
take an expectation of over the brighter
rule that i showed you before turns out
that this is the value on a spin
expectation that a random provers going
to get okay which is always bigger than
one remember that the honest prove it
all will earns a most to so what's going
to happen does anybody see a problem
at this point well if you do multiple
times what's going to happen so if
already on two executions the rand
improver is going to hurt more than the
honest prove ER so the honest prover is
computing computing computing because he
has to read at least n inputs to do the
right the right word the right job but
the bad provers answering a random and
is collecting more money just by by
answer in other words if there is a
large number of computation exactly the
volunteer computation and we approvers
who are buying to solve this problems as
fast as they can which is exactly what
happens in city at home or the protein
folding then if an honest prove it takes
on time to solve this problem and earns
two dollars but the rand improver takes
one and there's one dollar more than one
dollar in the time they takes the bonus
word solve one problem the dishonest
work is going to solve many is going to
hurt more money in other words a sloppy
fast answer is the rational strategy
rather than this low correct one okay so
what and this is independent of scaling
exactly I can scale my my my reward by
whatever multiplicative factor this is
still going to be a problem stealing
work helpful 141 scaling helps to
somehow whatever you want to call the
cost as Adam is you know sort of
questioning you know but you can always
scale it to make sure that there is a
positive profit but then you're going to
be stuck with this problem so be honest
this is not was not in the to be fair to
the original others this was not in
their model so it's not like a problem
with their mo it's a problem the model
not a problem with the solution okay so
okay so here is a first attempt to
define what we want formerly what I
would like to have he so informally what
do I want what I want that if if I'm the
honest prover and I invest this much
computation and then there's a dishonest
prover who's going to invest
less computation than me that is honest
proved a shorter and less money than I
do okay so that's that's informally my
goal okay so one way to do that is to
say okay a rational proof is for a
function f is up in shark impossible if
for every poober PTL done every sequence
of input if computing on CX the honest
prove our cost this much but the
dishonest prover is going to work for
less then the reward that the honest
propagates should be bigger than the
reward the designs were again in this
okay actually there's a anybody sees a
problem with this it's such a very
simple problem and the problem here is
that I'm saying that this is true for
every sequence of inputs and this is not
going to be possible there could be
approval as some solutions already are
wired for a particular input and it's
going to give me the correct result but
it's going to do not work so that's okay
I can get that so what you need to do
you need to introduce a notion of
distribution over the inputs and you
know later we're going to make the
assumption that over the distribution of
the input the only way you can get the
correct result is by doing all the work
okay so that's and now if you if you
make this notion of looking at randomly
chosen input of our core dresser the
distribution now that at least
definition makes I hope makes sense okay
so so here's the definition remember the
definition definition says that if you
invest less cost less work then you
should earn less money okay to be
stateless here so you can I think that's
that's part drive well you can make the
definition of the way you want and then
in your prodigal you we're going to make
an assumption that it doesn't keep state
for example if you compute a circuit on
a certain input you wouldn't be able to
remember what you computed when you're
going to compute again
kind of stuff on stage right exactly
that's it that's a big kind of warm that
I'm still confused myself on how to sort
of do all that but i'll i'll talk about
that in a minute so i'll give you two
sufficient conditions and the first one
is actually very interesting so if if
there a word of the honest proper is
fixed and the cut and there is an upper
bound on the cost which of course there
is get what you really want is that the
reward that the honest the dishonest
prover receives in the city in this
execution the fraction of the reward
that the dishonest provo receives should
be smaller than the fraction of the cost
that he invested in the computation okay
and it's actually not that difficult to
prove that if this is true then the
definition is satisfied and a simpler
way to state the sufficient condition is
that the reward is at the r0 think of a
product in which I do a minimal check to
verify that you're giving me the result
the correct result and if something goes
wrong I won't pay you but if something
is right i will pay you then in the case
the rewards that are or zero then P
tilde is the probability that you do you
receive the full reward then the
actually that's what you need that this
probability is less than the fraction of
the cost so the interesting thing about
this definition is that you need to
create a relationship between the reward
and the amount of work which was
completely absent in the in the previous
work actually there is one work which
I'll mention in the next slide but in
this light actually there is a protocol
in the region of paper by as RM akali
that they only considering the
standalone model they'll actually
satisfy this definition and there's a
mall a solution in the PCP model what i
mean by the PCP model is that the prover
is going to write down a proof a
potentially long proof that the verifier
cannot handle and put it somewhere like
in a trusted memory location and then
the bear fight is just going to look at
a couple of location in that proof okay
so this works actually for any
polynomial time computation
the circuit computing the function then
on onion put X the proverb write down
the entire circuit and then the very far
you just choose one Gator random okay if
that gate is correct the verifier peas
are otherwise the ref I paid zero okay
clearly on expectation you want to write
the whole right proof because there's a
probability 1 over s they're all gonna
are going to catch you right so and
where's it okay and you can prove that
if you assume a cost model in which
basically the prover pays one to compute
em right down the gate then the
probability of surviving and getting the
reward even when I am giving the false
result is exactly the number of correct
gates that you bro divided the total
number of gates right and that's exactly
if you assume that that's you pay one
for every correct gate that you compute
them right down that's exactly the same
ratio so you're fine so even if they
were looking only understand alone this
bird the solution actually works also
force eventually could possible although
it really is kind of dependent on the
customer than that you using for example
for a cost model in which are paying 11
you need a cost to compute the gate and
another unit of course to write it down
that's actually doesn't work anymore
because the constant factors start
getting in the way so there was another
paper and online I'll taco are here
somewhere they also considered this
problem though with different definition
and the first slightly different model
and hear what they and this only works
when you have a really large number of
problems and here with basically I'm
paraphrasing their solution here is look
at the view of all this problem batch
them in instead of K choose a parameter
K okay and instead of paying the prover
every time the prove it does a
computation just wait for the prove it
to solve k or them when you get the
result of this K computation take 10
random and recompute it yourself ok and
now if the result is correct the
going to pay off k computation why you
going to pay zero okay now this also
works because you're you need to make an
assumption and I skip this one you need
to make an assumption and this is what
you're saying you don't keep state and
all of that that the only way you can
compute your function is by actually
computing it okay on this input
distribution the only way you can get
the correct result is only if you
compute if you run the actual algorithm
there's no other better way to do it
okay so in that case the amount of work
that you do to return until the correct
policy is until this little see where
cease the cost of one execution answer
the probability that you get the reward
even when you're behaving correctly
again is less than the ratio of your
cost divided by the total cost however
this require your k the number of
problems to be large enough if you want
to keep this verifier efficient right so
that the cost of computing f1's should
be amortized over your k execution
otherwise the verifier is basically
recomputing f and there is no advantage
a time competing here herself okay yep
yeah verify these very small probability
checks work otherwise just this is it
this is it that's it but if catches the
proceedings and the prover has to
basically go bankrupt and they they did
so that's what i'm saying i'm
paraphrasing here okay this is exactly
their protocol actually has this sort of
like negative rewards in which i pay you
every time and then there is a part of
it that is kept in escrow and then if I
ever catch you cheating I'm going to
assess you a negative reward but again
because I'm recomputing the thing myself
you need this number K of problems to be
large enough to one more ties the
complex it if you still want your verify
to be little o of the original
computation okay I sort of simplified
their approach by saying instead of
introducing negative rewards and escrow
know what their I just either pay you
all of them
or don't pay or even if you just by
checking one them so so what we came up
and this is the part that is to me at
least not as satisfactory as I would
like it to be is a protocol that is
basically into an interactive version of
the PCP protocol of Azaria McCauley so
you start with an ultimate then this
works for on it arithmetic circuit so
you start with an arithmetic circuit of
that be and what the prove it does sense
the upper and the two and let's assume
that is bound if any instances too and
he sends the APPA and the two inputs of
the gates and what the very far does the
very fires check the back gate is
correct and then it recursos on one of
the two inputs a random on the
subcircuit that computes that input okay
so you give me the prove it gives me the
result of the computation it tells me
the upper gate was the two inputs of the
upgrades were in zero and in one and I
said okay I checked that if the check
fails I'm not going to pay you I've been
repeated 0 and then I'm going to select
one of this doing put so random and I
recurse the protocol on the subcircuit
yeah so this is the protocol you can see
that first of all this protocol is a
standalone rational proof for log depth
circuits and that's why what because the
probability of obtaining their word even
when giving an incorrect result can be
you can show that it's 1-2 to the minus
D and so it's logarithmic the gap is a
lot of movement these log the reason is
that p team that once I if I give an
incorrect result then the the the the
dishonest proofer can compute one sub
circuits correctly and give me one
correct result and one incorrect result
and then hope then I'm going to select
the correct one so with probability half
but every level is going to survive so
probably the hat so that the probability
that I'm
the tectum is running a lobby 2 to the
minus T okay because then at the last
level I'm going to check the inputs and
I'm going to okay the sequential
composability relies again on this
assumption that the only way you can
compute the right value of a wire is by
computing the sub circuits they leads to
that wire okay then and here is then we
need to have the circle to have up to
property the first one is the circle
which is what we call a regular circle
it basically what he means is that yeah
why can't you use a real PCP I missed
something why can't the prover just give
you a real piece appears the verifier
may not be able to handle the entire PCP
your the PCP model you can but you need
to have what do we do in with our
commitment right we do merkel on the pcp
to have a log verifier we do not call
right you can do crypto I'm trying to do
maybe I should I said at the beginning I
don't want to do crypt otherwise all
those narcs okay this is all information
theoretic in fact and this is not in my
obey a very good question which also
we've been working on is the define and
design a notion of rational commitment
meaning something which I commit to a
value and I release the correct value
that I committed not because I'm bound
by a cryptographic condition but I'm
bound by maximizing my utility if I had
that that I could just take the PCP
protocol and use that so this works
again for log dead circuits which have
some sub this what we call a regular
circuit meaning that basically every sub
circuit looks the same and and in and
then you need remember you need that
this probably this is the probability of
success remember this probability of
success for the prove it should be less
than C tilde / see I think I left this
somewhere else so remember this is the
condition that I need
so a level one this is a half that means
you need to compute level one of the
circle you need to do a half of the work
to a level two would be three quarters
some India to trick Wars the work
basically the number of Gators to double
I've every at least double at every
level and one example this is the
circuit that computes won a 50 co
efficient and I sort of made us happy
because FFT is one of the protocols that
are used a lot in this volunteer
computations and you can improve things
sama by iterating the protocol are times
and reducing the probability of error to
to this but then the complexity of the
verifier will always increase you can
also use a mixed strategy for example
here just exemplify on the circuit that
given the point representation of a
degree and minus one polynomial to boost
the value of the polynomial enough
another point this circuit is basically
an FF FF st circuit that goes from the
point of the coefficient representation
and then an evaluation circuit that
brings it down to the actual value in
this case and you get school what
happens is that you you can either put
yourself in a condition let me see okay
you can either use the check by re
execution in honest paper on at least
every log in executions and for less
than log and execution then you can
prove that our strategy works even if
your protocol is not much deeper than
not log and brought I means one Logan
okay so so let me just summarize so what
we do so we define this notion of
sequential com possibility and we want
to make a goal that answer correctly
always is the rational strategy and we
prove the some rational problems
probably not satisfied the tree sure
what other do when we present a new
protocol that I see if it for certain by
the death circuits now what is the
problem that there are many problems one
for example even in the standalone case
we don't have a rational proof for any
polynomial time computable function we
have the PCP a protocol but not a
information theoretic it doesn't use
cryptography protocol it works for any
polynomial time computer function a
better sequentially compose a protocol
that would work for any bandit that
Cirque enough this weird circuits that
we sort of came up with and also other
example of interesting problems we were
just stuck with a 50 because anyway
that's all we care there are circus that
can be used with with our protocol
that's it thank you